[Music]
honoring the lives lost on 9 11. tonight
the professional firefighters of nevada
hosted a memorial procession in downtown
las vegas the annual tribute only lasted
a couple of minutes but made a big
impact on those at the fremont
experience madison kimbrough joins us
live in the area tonight with the
details madison
21 years ago our country was bombarded
with tragedy but tonight las vegas came
together in remembrance
at that time the world just kind of
stopped
the fremont street experience looked a
lot different sunday evening as locals
tourists military and first responders
all gathered on maine and fremont for a
9 11 memorial procession the
professional fighter fighters of nevada
led the tribute procession in
partnership with the city of las vegas
those around recalling how impactful 9
11 was in their own lives many in
disbelief that it was actually 21 years
ago to the day i worked in the trade
center for 17 years we lost about 40
individuals i've also lost about
25 friends who are firemen history of it
will never change the
time passes but it still seemed caring
the effect on us
and then it's like since 9 11 the
craziness in the world is just gets more
bizarre and more bizarre after the march
there was a moment of silence followed
by a toast corey whitlock with the
professional fighter fighters of nevada
says having this annual event is a
reminder of the hard work first
responders go through on a regular basis
as these men and women every single day
step out to their fire stations put on
those bunker pants and go to these calls
and respond daily they feel that realism
and it's just a way that we can bring
our community together
the procession lasted about 15 minutes
and concluded here on third street in
collaboration with hogs and heifers bar
and downtown grand hotel and casino
reporting live in downtown las vegas
madison kimbrough 8 news now